what's going on there reject nation g
j here today to watch the movie nobody
you can run and watch this movie for a while as
you can see we've been doing a lot more movie
reactions here at the real rejects as of late so
subscribe and click the notification bell to get
notified when our next reaction is up also full
length watch along where you sync up with the
time code for nobody will be at our patreon
page cover a whole bunch of crap over there
as well thanks to all of become superjects
but if you can't do that the least you can
do is leave a like and a comment we're very
very much appreciated and then the handsome
devil's over at prepper thank you guys so much
for doing this but yeah i love the trailer for
this love bob odenkirk can't wait for the next
season to better call saul let's get into this
protect the cat oh kitty where the [ __ ] are you
me um
come on
garbage day mr
so routine
did he get the garbage it'll
end with him getting the garment
put the phone down gosh now that's about
all there is that's it i'll use a debit card
note give me your ring give me a [ __ ] ring
i'm married to your wife now no son
let him go son what i said let him go
yeah [ __ ] pop your [ __ ] your [ __ ]
nobody's talking to him did you even take a swing
she had it could have taken her
dad you know if that was my family
we're gonna get out of your hair and
just leave that garage door closed okay
you're a shitty cop you know
that you're so condescending
that was my family i would risk getting
my family killed i wouldn't have been a
you had a golf club they only
had guns you had it coming man
oh no yeah i was an auditor so kind of a
nobody pretty dry story don't care i just
want to finish up the project and call
it a day what about you uncle charlie
i actually already left him a message he tried
grandpa he actually saw some action yeah maybe
if you were his offspring oh
and um you missed the garbage
i just really want the garbage taken out
could you put it out the night before maybe
oh i took all the coffee it's reasons like
this why will smith slapped chris rock
can't keep a handle on things at home
pretty cool huh yeah the old man croaked
you didn't have much to leave but at least
i got something out of it honey come on
at least i got this compensation machine
out of it 4.9 liter v8 0 to 60 and
i'm about to find the [ __ ] out oh
he's going to hijack that at some point
0-60 i'm going to find out here in this
residential neighborhood i was just trying to
keep damage to a minimum yeah how's that working
out for you everybody's safe so jesus safety's on
keep my sister safe bro
they got rob from it's always sunny to be
oh good spot your son will never find
you hey oh it's the office still okay
sorry i'm thinking you did the best thing you
could bullseye i mean you being you holy crap
that's michael ironside i had electrical
tape on the handle just smith and wesson
hadn't been shot in a long while it was uh
ha ha ha ha now i know why you didn't
do what you didn't do hmm interesting
i know what you're thinking about and i
wish it wasn't don't do nothing stupid
hear me the pop resembling that his own
state visualizer to pop himself oh man
better an actor movie find it you can't
find what my kitty cat bracelet where was it
um here you sons of [ __ ] gonna kill those two
i'm sure it'll turn up somewhere oh god he snapped
i think you could hear the moment i all i think
was a kitty cat bracelet yeah sensing a theme in
these guys movies there's this thing i gotta do
then you best go do it
love it love it agent mansell fbi
your id is a badge expired by
about 20 years and i'm pretty
sure that ain't you in the photo who are you
oh she had my tattoo done just a man i was
looking for someone probably shouldn't flash
cheese like that around here bro there are
three types of people who as you say flash
cheats blue don't know any better people who are
seeking to intimidate and people like me who wish
with every fiber there being that someone
would try to take it from them oh god uh
thank you for your service
i'm getting out of here should
have called this movie wrist hats
i just locked us barricaded himself
smooth brother send me in the direction of
this person oh right there louise rico anymore
oh my god damn the kitty cat bracelet
give me the goddamn kitty cat bracelet
kill the baby kill it the baby that
baby has that bracelet i swear to god
oh why didn't you get the kitty cat bracelet
they say god doesn't close one door without
opening another please god open that door
he just needs an excuse to break bad
this girl's gonna get home safe tonight
right for me i hope these
[ __ ] like hospital food
i'm gonna [ __ ] you yeah you are
nice house
jesus
nice
get back up you are now reborn evil
dies tonight there you go buddy
oh my god
he's going so hard on them
yes oh god
ah now you've done it
oh my god
oh he's choking on his own
blood man that guy's gonna die
oh no don't tell me oh no oh no
sorry about the mess
i was gonna say maybe murdering
them is a little too far
that'll be fine hey hey i couldn't
sleep i was thinking about the garbage
it's been a hell of a day i can
see that just like old times huh
oh so she knows about his past look i miss you
i'm always right here i feel like
she's a little excited about it
she's gonna bring a spark back
what a badass jay walking like that
oh yeah
oh my god that's so violent wow oh
my god that's so violent oh jesus
hey
oh my god so painful
he attacked us unprovoked one
man are you [ __ ] with me
everything is a weapon find this man
the bus has a camper ride the metro all
night and you'll find him eventually
one of those guys was the brother of
you leave this off and you don't want
to [ __ ] with him hutch i'm serious ask the
barber he knows it was an isolated incident
how about i make that lasagna
that you love tonight you know
from scratch like i used to it's been
a while lasagna i'd really like that
i love that little girl it's the most beautiful
ray of sunshine writer's like how do little girls
talk exclamation marks but what i do know is
if he doesn't know who you are yet he will soon
what have you got from me i found his dad
he's got him a nursing home downtown no damn
you can't recognize a wolf in ship's clothing i
question the impliability of your employment here
i think if he had his way he'd probably
walk away with gonna watch all this money
no
crap no need to pay
too much i don't think you just leave russian i
mean he almost started to fire her so you know
because you know bro oh no jesus
christ everybody gets in the basement
oh don't call 9-1-1
bit of a video video they can watch
you very entertaining movie yeah
oh it's gonna be gruesome oh my god nice
hit him with the lasagna ah very cool
lasagna smash
damn
oh cool oh man you're reduced
to the equity of the house
only your son got to see some of them
oh
worth it
yes
he would have died just saying
and i do not ever suspend those belief in
my movie-going experience yeah how how much
blood alone has he spat out he pulled
out he got no blood left in his body
it used to be what they call an auditor for
those three letter agencies auditor as in the last
guy any organization wants to see at their door
i used to make sure that
there was no one left to it
bored him to death that thing i had
to go do it escalated heads up okay
no don't let him be the always lost moment no
he'll kick their asses too lasagna is ruined oh
crap symbolizing
hey guys so i need your help to clean this up
i need to take care of this what is this it is
what it is i need you to trust me right now
come on casab um close that distance come back
deal with us then we will see a couple's
counsel right then oh fellas here we are
three million bucks from a u.s military base
in revolto italy and his prize was me looming
over him with walter ppk no wait uh it was uh
suppressed hnk usb alan was living in boise idaho
he had a wife she came with two kids nothing there
to skim and he was smiling like a goddamn buddha
bone burns to ash at 1500 degrees and this
basement is designed to double that so they
won't be finding you among the rubble
it lasted a lot longer than i expected
go take your neighbor's car baddest
ass needle drop of all time i see
trees pretty awesome and vinyl
is highly flammable good call
start a whole new life off the cribs
better have a gun or that
blanket gramps his hands are guns
please turn that [ __ ] down
what a g
runs in the family i'm buying this place we
put our blood sweat and tears into this place
breathe breathe okay
i don't give a [ __ ]
and hutch's balls grew three sizes that day
oh no i thought he had a big-ass gun for
a second it's a shoulder-mounted cannon
oh come out of hiding man he's
trapped in martin shkreli's penthouse
okay so he's in america i thought her second
thought that he was back in russia no he's nearby
on it check their receipts jesus
does she took the pain yeah
but it takes tomorrow with you
god opened a hell of a door for you man
oh cool that's cool
i don't think i've ever
seen that in a movie before
hey
what say you and i have a moment
leave us stunt team we'd like to end our little
tattoo tape right now what's done is done after
all we can both rebuild right hm wait i do i
burned it all of it everything you have oh my god
you didn't even know oh god you could come after
me and if you succeed in taking me down well
you're still obligated to refinance the entire
op shack which begs the question can you
maybe uh open a tiki bar in one of
the lesser-known caribbean islands
and live your life far from me and
mine i um think it over i'll be nearby
oh oh boy
nate
resourceful resourceful guy
stay down
oh
i love it
showdown
oh dude oh
gang's all here
oh
oh my god
i love it safety first there's so many
great little production design details here
oh jesus oh [ __ ]
awesome dang and that uses the kickback
great shot mvp
oh ouch
jesus there we go there's
your john wickmuffle gunkata
i got the gun back yes
that's a sick family twisted
i'd love to see it behind the scenes on that
no
that was a great shot there's some amazing action
shots in here whoa oh my god he is that is bad wow
gross
oh yeah the beginning of
the movie i forgot all that
was the kitty becca it's me i
owe you
who the [ __ ] are you nobody
that ain't much of an answer
yeah yeah what
let him go ask no further questions
and get that cat some more food
he just took out a whole russian operation you
should be thanking this man by chance you name
it this kitchen's got it and with that we've i'm
sorry that's okay i know they're life go ahead
thanks give them the house yeah
no questions asked yeah for you
hot shear
does this house have a uh a basement
cool snap diggity that's great terrific the
flew by absolutely i really flew by damn
david admirable train for waiting for post credits
now all righty there's gotta be one it's gotta be
a setup for the future john wick crossover we just
watched the setup for the future another setup
for more futures that's his personal future i'm
talking about the franchise future he got a call
from the unknown and so we don't know exactly what
it is but that being that he's being contacted
about something all right fine then i'll change
my hopes to an innocuous joke post-credit scene
that doesn't amount to anything got his daughter
the kitty it's like a wolfman story it absolutely
is yeah sometimes a little more of a rhythm i
feel like there's a post-credit scene coming yeah
tell me again about that guy who shot
him stairs was three guys pops three
i still don't believe you well it still happens
why can't we just fly there with this luggage
sick sons of [ __ ] it's in the family
man that is hey man i mean did grandpa
probably her dad to them probably uh taught
him how to do that three guy sniper shot
i love it the whole thing is wolf in
sheep's clothing it's like the entire movie
this guy who's it's who literally is born into
being this person and he wants something else
but it is just a veneer yeah it's like
a werewolf movie where you watch where
you meet someone who's actually already sort of
conquered their affliction only to then discover
they actually want to lean into it and let it back
out i mean yeah they haven't but it's like he's
hungry that's what that first act is he's just
hungry for more he wants he wants to feed again um
yeah yeah no yeah yeah it's that that blood hunger
it's like once he gets that first taste he
holds back it's like oh it starts the jones
you know but there is a yeah like that it was
a moral conundrum because it was it was a weird
turn on things when the couple breaks in they
heard the russians in it and the girls sounded
russian when she first started speaking i was
like oh the latinos but i thought it was an
interesting turn of events of how he goes in
there and he decides like okay kitty bracelet
was taken felt the shame it's time for him to get
revenge just lets them go that's the end of what
happened there with that couple who came in and
kicked off this whole event for him in his life
and they just stumbles onto something else because
it they brought it back to he just wants to feed
it's not about getting revenge you know and
i thought like oh what an interesting turn
i thought it was gonna be like oh john wick
like kind of someone breaks in and then he's
here to get revenge now and oh but
he took revenge on the wrong people
and it's led to all this so i thought it was kind
of a cooler through line that it's this all stems
because he just had to get back to who he was you
know yeah it's like a super personal journey like
you they set up all these things and i'm sure
that they do factor in like oh man i've just
got to prove himself to his son he's got to you
know like re-establish himself as you know like
the alpha of this family but it's really not
about that at all i wish they brought some
of that back at the end yeah or something with
his son yeah since that was that seemed to be a
definite focus of a big part of what he was
feeling ashamed about was wanting to be like
feel like a man in front of his family in front of
his son especially you know i think we got like uh
enough you know like when he sees he's all messed
up he's like hey i'm proud of you hey tackle that
guy then his son comes up and sees like oh my god
my dad's a badass my dad took all these dudes but
i didn't want a moment with him and his son just
like something like even if it was like a an
exchange of looks between each other like that is
his son really you you get that emotional beat is
i guess is what i sort of wanted that's also like
he i like how it's it's both like you he loves his
family and he's really soft and sensitive towards
them i just think freaking bob odin plays those
nuances so well yeah and those uh it's officially
over we'll continue talking about it now
i think he plays this those um nuances
so incredibly well of it's like when he
wipes off the board of like 240 days till uh
since it's an accident or something happens
you know like a lot of movies that try to have
a little bit of that humor to their shoot em up
flicks can be a little excessive and like
i get the joke you know like sometimes i
it felt lived in here versus i got the joke all
right he's a family man yeah they didn't do an
insert on it and make it a whole moment it's
that thing of like you could almost miss it if
you weren't really fully aware or of or paying
attention to what the gag is it feels really
natural the way everything works in that regard of
him being a family man like of how like something
like the movie shoot him up or something like mr
mrs smith might overdo it like i get your husband
and wife and your family jokes you know hey it's
kind of a cartoon it's heightened and you're
having fun with that i understand i thought they
did it just enough in here to the point where it
never became annoying and would come at surprising
moments and there wasn't like an uh it wasn't like
ever a moment of over bantering yeah even amongst
the family dynamics it gets a little far-fetched
for me when old man christopher lloyd shows up
at the end and it's like no one can shoot him
around it's fun it's funny it's a little i was the
one who got shot um but yeah like i thought the
mobile reason the chair and the russian guy show
up and he like pulls out his sawed-off shotgun and
blasted i thought that was a cool moment and but
yeah when he's at the warehouse itself i'm like
it's a little much but that's so cool yeah yeah
yeah yeah you've earned it you were in this movie
yeah and i mean it it adds because of just the
scenario and because of like christopher lloyd
like the presence that he brings just because
we know christopher lloyd and then too yeah
he is as much performances yeah yeah yeah like
there's a charm and a cheekiness to that that is
just in fitting enough with the movie to make it
okay it's like it's it's the movie has some hype
but like you you name check those other movies and
it's not going for that level of craziness and so
i feel like yeah it approaches with christopher
lloyd maybe the ceiling of that but it doesn't
for me go beyond to the point where i'm like
i'm kind of pulled out of this now you know
yeah cause when i saw the trailer it came
back to me just now i remember with the kitty
kitty bracelet moment like you're really
that guy said [ __ ] like when he's screaming
i thought the movie was going to be that
the whole time instead of john wick's dog
it's his daughter's bracelet yeah i thought it
would just be a bunch of jokes about him like
you know being a family man too and but it wasn't
you know it really wasn't it felt like that's just
to his character as it felt like a person we
were watching accept himself like this was this
bob owner crooks really great at playing those
relatable guys who have uh walk around with a
sense of shame you know and it's a shame of like
what his past is but he's also not proud of who
he is now because he's got to repress who he
really feels like he is internally and as this
wolf man story is going on he by the end accepts
who he is and looks like he repairs his marriage
and is able to have a fresh start while being on
the stage of acceptance of the kind of man that he
really is and he got to show his family too so i
think it's a this is a cool story and i did find
myself legit concerned for him at one point i was
i was actually worried whereas when you compare it
because this is the same right from john wick and
the movie was constantly compared when i heard it
where as opposed to um you know john wick i'm
never really worried for john wick in that film
word for everyone else yeah because the way he
fights he escalatingly gets smoother throughout
this film yeah you know watching a guy literally
shake the dust off yeah because in the first bus
fight he's getting his ass kicked quite a bit um
but he's he's like rocky balboa you know he brawls
he's bulldogging like no matter and i think that's
what's cool distinguishing the fighting styles
he just gets in there rough and tumbled in style
you know he's not clean about it but by the time
you get to the finale where he is very strategic
about it that's when he's at its smoothest with
how he handles everything and so i think it's
cool to watch a guy go through rough tough
and then like that first fight he gets hurt a
lot he gets thrown through the window you know
and then the second fight at his family home it's
still kind of like that gets a few hits on him
and then by the time you get to the finale
it's just like oh no he's he's he's bad he's
who he's he's who he says he used to be yeah
yeah absolutely yeah i mean i think that it
does really nicely to separate itself from john
wick especially in that way of yeah you have
like with john wick when it kicks off
it's like oh his skills haven't aged a day
you know like he is completely kind of
ready to jump back into this whereas here
you're watching this internal debate happen
throughout and i really like like it's
realized in dialogue it's realized in scenes but
i think a lot of it is mostly in the performance
of just the internal stuff that bob odenkirk
is really good at throwing out there so that
yeah you are watching this sort of back and forth
within this man and i love the way they handle the
the initial robbery because it as the movie goes
on picks up this quality where it's like okay
in that full sheep's clothing mode it's probably
look i know what i'm capable of these are just
two punks who are you know desperate and afraid
i don't want to destroy them right now but also
that comes at a cost of yeah it's the over
correction and so it is fascinating to watch
a hitman movie where the point i feel like there's
so many like hitman or x badass brought back into
the fold movies where it's about obviously the
tension between the normal quiet life and the
killer but here it's less about picking one or the
other or or it's really yeah just about leaning
into that and finding the most actualized life
for yourself based on what you're good at and
what you love yeah and i love yeah the way that
it's more about striking the balance rather than
it is about i gotta get out and do one last job or
i'm back and i gotta you know prove supremacy it's
like you get the sense that when he gets the call
he's actually a little bit bummed to have to like
go back to work so quickly yeah and so yeah like
they really pinned together uh the the at-home
stuff and the nitty-gritty you know violent action
stuff into what feels like a well-rounded complete
package for the most part yeah storytelling
wise i think they really cared about that a lot
i thought it was just going to be a big style over
substance with a great bob odin correct movie yeah
performance i thought that's what it was going
to be like a great bob motocross performance in
a super stylish film yeah i was kind of surprised
by oh you you care a lot more about the character
storytelling than i expected yeah expecting it
to be one of those scenarios where it's like the
cast really elevates like a pretty straightforward
script but yeah it's like the scripting i thought
had a thoughtful quality to it along with all your
cool action movie tropes and foreign coming out of
hardcore henry yeah i really appreciated this
movie's restraint because there are i mean yeah
obviously that guy has a knack for stylish action
but i thought that it avoided for me at least
doing too much style only for the sake of style
like you could argue that shot where the gun
flips and then rizzo catches it it's just
like super cool you earned that at the finale
at the finale it's like yeah you're unleashed
at that point but there are so many great really
deliberate just like pans or warner shots that
serve to really sell the action and to really make
it feel tangible and coming out of something that
is so kinetic and fran and frenetic and frantic
like hardcore henry to see something like this
that is like really restrained and then hulks
out when it needs to like it really does in a
completely action movie kind of way embody that
sort of seething simmering anguish at the heart
of like a werewolf kind of story so like i thought
this was a cool growth for that guy as a director
as well you know well it's like the first the only
one or that you have of this movie is the one with
the introduction of the of our villain the russian
bad guy yeah and it is a great introduction you
know that's something i don't want to make this
just a john wick competition i think the reason
why i'm doing that is because that's all i heard
about this movie this like it was just constantly
compared and i get it like it's a dude who's a
formerly a hitman and then fights the russians
yeah like i totally see why people compare i
can't disregard that um it's but there are things
here that i think like store like when you think
about john wick that's a different type of movie
in the sense that that's a not as funny in the in
in the way how this is more overtly funny and also
it's um like there's more of like a fun pop zest
to this film yeah versus that ironic humor yeah
yeah exactly and that one the motive for what
he's doing is very different uh like john wick is
a pure revenge film where this is it comes from a
selfish desire essentially is where this comes
from and then it becomes about protecting yeah
you know and so and i hear that word
will smith really ruin that word for me
so he's coined that phrase now um so yeah it's
a very different type of thing and i think too
with terms of your russian bad guy i'd say
for the most part does he lose uh some of
the threatening weight as the movie progresses
yeah by the time freaking bob odenkirk shows up
at the club at the club is incinerating the money
and everything you're like okay this guy's not
threatening ain't got [ __ ] but at first you know
it is it is threatening and the way they build him
up i think is really cool uh that they they do
that's when i was i am a little concerned because
the way they they um the picture they paint
of the kind of batty he is sounds scary and
the kind of guy you wouldn't want to mess with
and i think the way they they fleshed out the um
uh the world that our main character comes
on is this hutch is real actual name um but
okay the way they flesh out the world there
was some noise going out there the way they
flesh out the world that hutch comes from i think
the way they they spread out the little bits of
information about his backstory was really well
done like how he just tells a son up front like
i was an auditor and yet sounds
like it was it's his cover story
and then you find out that that's actually
what he was titled yeah and why he was titled
that i'm like oh that's really cool because he
could just be upfront with his i was an auditor
but not the kind of auditor you actually think he
was and the way they handled the backstory with
his wife like it sounds like his
wife knew something about him
because she wasn't surprised when she saw him
and she was you know tending to his wounds and we
don't know much about how they met necessarily but
the way they allude to what they were like at the
beginning when starting a new starting a life like
this was exciting for him when starting a family
was exciting for him and then now that he's just
only doing that how that it's lost a lot of that
flavor for them and even that cliche assassin
story of the day that changed was the day he
didn't kill this guy because he heard his story
but i thought the way that played out and how that
influenced his decision to do the family i'm like
oh that's fresh like it's very cliche to be like
you had the gun to the back of the guy's head and
then he couldn't pull the trigger for some reason
yeah and then for him to like do the whole i
caught up with him saw he was actually he cleaned
up and he has a family life and that that made him
want to have that as well i think is refreshing
there's a lot of unique things i think they did
here and they they kept the life throughout and i
feel like visually there was a lot of cool like
visual illustrations that they they point out
that an average audience member i think could
latch onto you know they they framed a lot of
the way him and his wife are a lot of the shots
were like they're separated yeah there's usually
something that is a divide it's like a physical
divider between them yeah the pillow or the car
when they're in the garage you know yeah yeah
barriers and use of negative spaces or like
claustrophobic framing you know when they're
talking to each other directly yeah but i
wanted to see some there are some wrap ups that
i would have liked to have seen like i wanted to
see the daughter get the kitty i wanted to see the
daughter get the kitty bracelet i wanted something
with the sun there are some emotional beats i
cared about that i cared about the family stuff
yeah for sure so i wanted a little bit of buttons
there um but it i it would be a lie to say i left
dissatisfied by the time it ended well this
reminded me kind of of how i almost feel like
hitman movies like this are sort of like garage
rock where it's like yeah there are like a lot of
pieces of this a lot of the chords are the same as
like a million things you've seen but when you put
them in an interesting order and you put in a few
interesting flourishes something can feel quite
new and when you have enough unique little twists
on the idea like like you were talking about with
letting that guy go like that's when these things
can really sing and it is simple and all it takes
is some expressive communication of the themes
of the story through the filmmaking i feel like
this is a good example of one that didn't get too
lost in the weeds of you know putting a bunch of
cool effects and filters and stuff like that it
just went with okay what's the song we're playing
how do we accentuate it the most while
also keeping it straight forward and to
the point and uh and yeah like how would you
describe the the choice of songs like i feel
like you would bet be better at articulating let
me attempt and then you re-write what i'm saying
is that i think the choice of songs because
obviously they're the choice of songs our
character is using in this movie they feel like
because they're such oldies music you know they're
from such a different era kind of like the bygone
era of our character as well so i love that it was
constantly those were the needle drops of the film
yeah yeah i think you're you know i think you're
absolutely right it's like it's hearkening they
sound like you know they're peppy and they are
you know warm and inviting and they feel they
are of an older time so it feels like something
more quintessential and classic like you know the
american family household or whatever but also in
the lyrics you know i don't feel very intentional
yeah it doesn't i don't have a great recollection
of every song but i feel like the irony and the
clever part about choosing those is that yeah they
have this familial home equality within the sound
but when you dig within the lyrics they actually
seem to be speaking to these things that actually
want to get out of him or to you know be sort of
acknowledged and that's the thing that music
is really great at is you know is carrying a
certain level of dramatic irony when you contrast
what the lyrics are saying with the sound and i
feel like this it's like there's that there's
that one moment where they use heartbreaker
which is like a pretty badass you know it's like
that's your quintessential action movie rock tune
moment and i thought that was placed nicely amid
all these other ones because yeah it's sort of
the duality to me of his life is sort of the sound
is something he he does care for and he does want
that warmth and when he's looking there's that one
shot and i don't remember if it was underscored
with music but where he's looking into the house
the warm light is bathed on him but he's outside
everything is really cold and so i feel like the
lyrical content does a good job in those songs of
complimenting the theme of what his character is
experiencing feeling wanting to let out without
being like a song choice where it's like oh you
chose this for the lyrics i get it you know yeah
yeah yeah i thought they were they're well chosen
yeah it's an excellent film i think for what it is
and uh i think it's freaking excellent and um the
it becomes a little cartoony with rizza and the
dad yeah a little cartoony but there's something
also charming about it yeah it's a family reunion
stuff yeah it is and i like the cam even though
a lot of the chemistry form with rosa is through
the um kind of player is that oh yeah i'm not
i'm not 100 sure but yeah just like an old-time
radio transmitter yeah a lot of the communication
is formed through that i think there is a good
chemistry there by the time he shows up it's
really rewarding one even the use of that like
when he when you're used to seeing him on that and
then he calls him on the phone and he's like you
just want to get this number traced yeah like yeah
it communicates the urgency even just through that
motif you know true well chosen guys what do
you think about the movie nobody leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that bell
hit that like button and hey let's do a page
david gandy i just wanted to say thank
you for inspiring this biopic of your life
i feel like if anybody out there is itching
to let the beast out it's you david you got such a
lovely demeanor you're a kind good-hearted guy and
that's that's you but you're also a successful
accomplished martial artist and i feel like you
probably have a little pent-up rage that you
need to go out there on the streets and just
let out you know you're like family to us and i
would feel very safe in your care and hey if you
could teach me a thing or two i would be very
grateful no you're not going to have me looking
at you like the sun in this movie i'm just going
to be all admiration david gandy so i hope you're
staying well and kicking ass out there and
we'll catch you next month catch you david you